NICK FURY
Heroes.
It's an old-fashioned notion.
No matter who wins or loses,
trouble still comes around.
COBIE SMULDERS
Nick Fury is such a central character
to this world. Like, his access to all of
these different Super Heroes,
and the way that he's
seemingly all-knowing.
NICK FURY
I got my eye on you.
KEVIN FEIGE
We always knew that Secret Invasion
would first and
foremost focus on Nick Fury.
And we really wanted to learn more about
him than we had ever learned before.
NICK FURY
This is my war. Alone.
SAMUEL L. JACKSON
One of the things we talk about is
Nick Fury is not a Super. His super-power
is his persuasiveness and fearlessness.
NICK FURY
I know the nature of this threat
way better than you ever will.
ALI SELIM
After the Blip, Nick Fury really questions
who he should trust. He's been on
S.A.B.E.R., and they bring him down.
MARIA HILL
For years, you've been avoiding Earth.
NICK FURY
Yeah, well, this is different.
ALI SELIM
He's a Nick Fury that we've never seen
before. And so, that immediately
demands for a more grounded series.
SAMUEL L. JACKSON
There's a real espionage element
to what's going on.
TALOS
Fury, we've got to be very careful now.
DON CHEADLE
Hopefully, it'll feel like
a different experience.
Something grittier.
NICK FURY
An invasion is here,
and we can't even tell
who the invaders are.
DON CHEADLE
We get to really dig into Fury
and the stakes that he's
having to encounter.
G'IAH
This is just the beginning.
NICK FURY
I'm the last person standing between them
and what they really want.